game konsole an das bekam beginn weg
gelobt worden was angeblich ist hier
fest zum nabel der zeit das perfekte
kind was sind niemals schreiben
hallo herr müller wird zwar eine kleine
stärkung und dann geht's ab du bist ja
erst mal herzlich eingeladen auch in
warschau ist auch hier will ich keinen
alkohol oder nicht ich will
direktzahlungen los wir haben drüben was
aufgebaut
los gehts jetzt wird gezockt die ema den
controller in die hand ja was ist der
controller der liegt direkt vor das ding
ja ich habe meine eigenen dabei die
profis dazu haben mit dem wir nicht
gewohnt zu spielen
steck competition das funktioniert nicht
da musst du leider mit den modernen
mitteln jetzt arbeiten geht nicht anders
das war nochmal schnell wenn er 2 r2 was
ist er zwei oben rechts so dass ja dann
sagt nach oben rechts er hat 2 alles
klar
ja es ist ein holpriger start aber es
ist noch kein meister vom himmel
gefallen dass noch luft nach oben aber
kriegst du hin
herr professor pfeiffer sie sind einer
der größten gegner des sports in der
sprache der zocker kann man sagen sie
sind so etwas wie der endgegner wenn die
das so sagen wollen sollen sie ruhig
also ich interessiere mich dafür
deswegen weil wir dieses extreme
absinken der schulischen
leistungsfähigkeit von jungen beobachten
versuchen sich mal zu überzeugen was
anderes zu machen als zuzogen
die mädels sind beim zocken nicht dabei
wer also strafe mädchen kennenlernen
will mit dem flotten will der kriegt sie
nicht dadurch dass er der sieger beim
sport geworden ist aber dass ich das
gern aber er gibt sie kriegt sie wenn er
in einen tanzclub geht wo er rock'n roll
tanzen kann ich will sie nicht
schockieren aber ein tanz controls
gerade nicht mehr so up to date herr
professor und gegen wen spielt jetzt
ging marie gegen mädchen frauen beim
sport was kommt als nächstes
echte frauen bei kindern das klischees
jahr zocken macht dumm fett man sitzt du
noch vom computer herum hat keine
sozialen kontakte mehr ist da was dran
naja also grundsätzlich wenn man zu viel
von einer sache macht ist da immer was
dran dann verblödet man wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen in eine richtung wird ein
fachidiot das kann man beim gaming
vielleicht auch passieren hat aber wenig
mit dem sport zu tun mit der leistung im
sport zu tun
du läufst in die falsche richtung
welches hatte ein eigenes dauer ja das
sagst du mir ja früh ich habe doch
gesagt links das gesagt ja links ja das
war die erste halbzeit
ich dachte du kennst die fußballregeln
nein wenn man jetzt wirklich
computerspiele professionell spielen
möchte dann muss man schon zeit
investieren zocken ist das was du aus
reiner lust und laune machst du setzt
dich an die konsole oder anderen handy
oder an deinen rechner und spielst ein
wenig aber hast nicht wirklich ein
leistungsgedanken weil die im
vordergrund und muss vielleicht auch
dann spielen wenn man mal keine lust hat
ok also zocken ist heute show und sport
ist heute journal
ich sehe nur ein gewinner aus
verschiedenen leuten pfeilen tasten ich
checke überhaupt gar nichts ist ja schon
mal schon mal ein fortschritt was machst
du da eigentlich
manche machen halt schnell fortschritte
und ein bisschen langsamer ist schon
kriegen was wohl dazu sagen wenn ich
welcher typ focus spielt und einige ganz
wenige unter 1 prozent schaffen ihr
damit ihren lebensunterhalt zu bedienen
aber diese 15 prozent der jungen
amerikaner zwischen 21 und 30
die nur nach computerspielen die leben
ganz überwiegend eben von müttern und
vätern und haben keine realeinkommen
keine lebensperspektive wohne auch noch
bei meiner mutter hat mir geschadet
natürlich nicht naja gut schon irgendwie
nicht wirklich
letztendlich bin ich in der handel von
der heute schon da ja
aber mal ehrlich so viel geld kommt auch
nicht warum noch aber das essen schmeckt
aber jetzt habe ich zumindest schon
einmal aufs tor
nee das ist ja ein tor ach so es war auf
mein tor so hast du schon mal spieler
erlebt die schlechter gestartet sind ja
es sind ja auch besondere umstände für
dich
man hatte einfach die dieser antwort
aber die frage nein nein nicht die
können mich mal der pfeifer hat recht
außerdem bin ich ohnehin her so der
aktive tür
er kann ja wirklich gar nichts zurück
ins studio
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye